[Música]
hay Argentina Argentina qué haríamos en
visualpolitiks en la Argentina de ser el
granero del mundo un potente exportador
de carne y tener muchísimas reservas de
gas petróleo y litio a estar
permanentemente sumergida en un bucle de
constantes problemas financieros y
económicos es la eterna contradicción
Argentina que os contemos que el país
está a punto de quebrar ya no es ninguna
novedad verdad y sin embargo así estamos
argentina se arruina por intentar frenar
el colapso total de su moneda El Banco
Central tiene más pasivos que activos en
su balance Dos de cada tres niños en
Argentina son pobres o están privados de
derechos básicos Argentina suma en 2022
un millón de nuevos pobres hasta el
39,2% de la población Pues bien en medio
de semejante contexto este pasado 13 de
agosto se han celebrado las primarias
abiertas simultáneas y obligatorias paso
una especie de elecciones donde todas
las fuerzas políticas están obligadas a
participar para elegir o ratificar a sus
candidatos y sabéis que sus resultados
han sido un auténtico bombazo los
argentinos han dicho basta hemos logrado
construir esta alternativa
competitiva que no solo dará fin al
cristianismo sino que además dará fin a
la casta política parasitaria chorre
inútil que une este país Javier milei el
libertaria outsider que llegó a la
política Argentina en 2019 ha ganado
contra todo pronóstico estas
particulares elecciones invito a los
argentinos a sumarse la revolución
liberal que va a ser que el 35 años
Argentina vuelva a ser una potencia
mundial Muchas gracias y la libertad
[__]
viva la libertad [__]
tal y como podéis ver se ha convertido
no solo en el candidato más votado
individualmente sino que con más del 30%
de los votos se ha puesto por delante
del resto de fuerzas políticas hoy
nos hemos puesto de pie para decirle
basta al modelo de la decadencia hoy
dimos el primer paso para la
reconstrucción de la Argentina y eso no
es todo tras años y años de hegemonía
política ahora el peronismo parece
herido de muerte acaba de obtener uno de
sus peores resultados electorales de
toda la historia y la pregunta es por
qué Qué explica su debacle Por qué el
gobierno de Alberto Fernández se hizo
tan impopular que puede suponer este
maremoto político para la argentina se
convertirá caso Javier milei en el nuevo
presidente de la república queridos
amigos amigas vamos a ver todas las
respuestas Y en un próximo vídeo aquí en
visualpolitik veremos también qué quiere
exactamente
este Nuevo León político para la
Argentina así que arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Argentina no solo ha sido el país de las
crisis durante años también fue el país
bandera de la inestabilidad política
entre los años 1930 y 1976 el país vivió
Ni más ni menos que seis golpes de
estado digamos que En aquellos tiempos
los militares tenían poca paciencia en
promedio los argentinos sufrían un golpe
de estado cada 2.800 días sin embargo
esta situación cambió por completo a
partir de
1983 cuando los militares se vieron
obligados a abandonar El Ejecutivo tras
la derrota de las malvinas
[Música]
la llegada de la Democracia supuso
retomar las garantías constitucionales
más elementales atrás quedaron los
tiempos de la censura y la represión sin
embargo Aunque el primer presidente
electo en esta nueva etapa democrática
Raúl Ricardo alfonsín tuvo bastante
éxito a la hora de reconstruir las
instituciones políticas fue todo un
desastre económico en 1989 cuando dejó
el poder el país registraba una
inflación anual de más del 4.900 por
ciento
Claro que luego llegó la remontada ya os
lo hemos contado aquí en visualpolitik
durante la presidencia de Carlos menem
entre 1969 y 1999 la economía Argentina
despegó como un cohete hasta que la
eterna adicción Argentina al gasto
público volvió a mandar todo al [__]
en 2001 todo se vino abajo el presidente
de la rúa tuvo que dimitir la economía
Argentina entró en thefault y en la
calle se produjo una ola de indignación
popular al compás de un grito que se
vayan todos Y sí aquí también se asaltó
el congreso
luego En las siguientes elecciones en
las del 2003 el candidato más votado en
primera vuelta fue de nuevo Carlos menem
pero sin opciones reales de lograr la
victoria decidió no presentarse a la
segunda vuelta Néstor kirchner asumió el
timón de Mando comenzó entonces La era
del kirchnerismo desde entonces han
pasado más de años de los cuales tan
solo cuatro han tenido un gobierno no
peronista nos referimos por supuesto al
de Mauricio macri entre 2015 y 2019 el
resto del tiempo el peronismo barra
kirchnerismo ha sido hegemónico en 2011
Cristina Fernández de kirchner logró
incluso la reelección con el 54% de los
votos en primera vuelta las suyas se
convirtió en la tercera candidatura con
más apoyo electoral de toda la historia
Argentina el peronismo kirchnerista por
sí mismo se había convertido en todo un
imperio y en 2019 tras la etapa de
Mauricio macri el primer líder
democrático no peronista en completar su
mandato en los últimos 90 años la
coalición peronista kirsenista el frente
de todos a razón los argentinos
desechaban de menos sin embargo este
mandato se hizo tan cuesta arriba que
todo ese capital y poder político empezó
a evaporarse y la pregunta es Qué
explica exactamente la debacle que está
sufriendo el peronismo Pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Cristina Fernández de kirchner y la
debacle peronista
Cristina Fernández de kirchner para bien
o quizás sobre todo para mal ha supuesto
un antes y un después para la política
Argentina tras la muerte de su esposo en
octubre del 2010 cfk se hizo con las
riendas del país y desde entonces se ha
convertido en uno de los personajes
políticos más controvertidos no solo de
Argentina sino también de toda América
Latina y quizás de todo el mundo
Hablamos de una líder política que nunca
ha dejado de estar en el candelero y que
siempre ha hecho todo lo posible por
manejar los hilos del poder por ejemplo
en 2019 apostó porque Alberto Fernández
un antiguo colaborador suyo y uno de los
peronistas más críticos con su figura
fuese el candidato a la presidencia
Mientras ella hacía y desafía desde la
vicepresidencia esa al menos era su
intención
y me dijo así que yo llegué a la
conclusión de que el candidato tiene que
ser vos no no me dijo yo voy a ser tu
candidata vicepresidenta
y ahí
entendí menos Y eso que hablamos de un
tipo que durante años estuvo repitiendo
acusaciones como esta es que una de las
cosas que nadie critico a Cristina es el
modo en que ha maltratado la justicia y
el maltrato de la justicia supone
también el maltrato a los fiscales El
caso es que con casi 13 millones de
votos el peronismo arrasó los argentinos
le dieron su confianza a este particular
tándem y ni siquiera hizo falta una
segunda vuelta empezó entonces una de
las legislaturas más complicadas y duras
que se recuerdan el día 10 de diciembre
de 2019 Alberto Fernández se convirtió
en Presidencia la idea era que Alberto
contribuyera a moderar el peronismo y lo
cierto Es que su mandato comenzó con una
altísima tasa de popularidad Sin embargo
la primera tormenta no tardaría en
estallar
apenas tres meses después de alcanzar la
casa rosada se desató la pandemia de la
covid-19 el gobierno argentino apostó
Entonces por establecer una de las
cuarentenas más largas de todo el mundo
en un primer momento en plena cuarentena
el índice de confianza en el gobierno se
disparó y batió su mejor registro en 15
años sin embargo este sentimiento no
tardó en darse la vuelta comenzó
entonces una caída libre que ha llegado
hasta nuestros días
por supuesto la pandemia y la aplicación
de una cuarentena larguísima hicieron
Mella en la economía y a eso le tenemos
que sumar noticias Como este impacto
político por la foto que muestra Alberto
Fernández de festejo en Olivos en plena
cuarentena el resultado es que en 2021
el gobierno estaba ya políticamente
hablando contra las cuerdas
prácticamente al límite Alberto
Fernández era menos popular que un
examen sorpresa un lunes a primera hora
el mito popular del peronismo de repente
se estaba sumando y cuando llegaron las
elecciones legislativas ya os podéis
imaginar lo que ocurrió
el oficialismo se dio un señor tortazo
fue una catástrofe electoral sobre todo
porque Incluso en importantes bastiones
peronistas del interior del país el
apoyo al frente de todos la gran
coalición oficialista hizo aguas y lo
más importante era el preámbulo de lo
que estaba por venir entre otras cosas
porque en política cuando ganas y
gobiernas es muy fácil hacer amigos pero
cuando pierdes Entonces los problemas y
las puñaladas se multiplican que es
exactamente lo que ocurrió la propia
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández hizo
pública una carta cargando toda la
responsabilidad sobre el presidente
señale que creía que se estaba llevando
a cabo una política de ajuste fiscal
equivocada que estaba impactando
negativamente la actividad económica y
por lo tanto en el conjunto de la
sociedad y que indudablemente esto iba a
tener consecuencias electorales no lo
dije una vez me cansé de decirlo y no
solo al presidente de la nación la
respuesta siempre fue que no era así que
estaba equivocada y que de acuerdo a las
encuestas íbamos a ganar muy bien las
elecciones Ese fue un punto de no
Retorno a partir de ahí el gobierno se
rompió por completo y comenzó un sálvese
quien pueda de repente Vimos a ministros
criticar al propio gobierno a la señora
Por las cuatro esquinas lo desastroso
que era Fernández y a todo el
cristianismo en bloque presionando para
cambiar la política económica
la situación llegó a tal punto que en
marzo de 2022 cuando el ministro de
economía Martín Guzmán logró alcanzar un
acuerdo con el fmi para reestructurar la
deuda Argentina parte de los diputados
kirchneristas votaron en contra en el
congreso lo que puso las conversaciones
con el fmi al borde del Abismo amigos la
lucha fratricida no solo hizo que
Fernández necesitara votos de la
oposición sino que terminó con la
dimisión del propio ministro de economía
y la implosión total del gobierno y del
peronismo las cosas estaban tan mal que
Alberto y Cristina probaron una solución
de última hora una última bala con el
gobierno al borde del default y la
inflación por las nubes acordaron poner
a Sergio massa un influyente político y
entonces presidente de la cámara de
diputados al frente del Ministerio de
economía y no sólo eso le dieron también
el Ministerio de la producción y el
Ministerio de agricultura es decir
básicamente en un momento en el que la
economía lo era todo le dieron las
llaves del gobierno el resultado no
cambió nada las cosas siguieron de mal
en peor Y ojo porque la perspectiva del
gobierno al menos públicamente es muy
diferente según ellos el problema El
auténtico problema de Argentina es que
el país ha ido demasiado bien Sí sí
demasiado bien Tal cual como lo
escucháis
tratando de acumular reservas en un
momento en que tenemos una demanda de
dólares muy grande porque la economía No
para de crecer el problema que tenemos
Es que la economía crece mucho la gente
percibe que ellos en su vida individual
están mejor pero que todo el mundo está
mal o que todas las situaciones está mal
esto es una construcción no es algo que
tiene que ver con la vida con la vida
cotidiana lo que por supuesto contrasta
por completo con la realidad Social para
que os hagáis una idea las cosas están
tan mal que decir hoy por hoy que
Argentina es un país deprimido ya no es
ninguna exageración la que fuera una de
las mayores potencias mundiales a
principios del siglo XX hoy lucha por
superar por no quedarse muy atrás de
países como Bulgaria o Rumanía este país
sigue batiendo récords y una de cada
cuatro personas tienen ya síntomas de
ansiedad y depresión evidentemente la
mala situación económica y profesional
tienen mucho que ver con todo esto por
mucho que el gobierno insista en decir
lo contrario
es decir teníamos sobre la mesa una
interminable crisis económica un
presidente tremendamente impopular un
oficialismo roto en bandos que se odian
y un gobierno que encima parecía vivir
en otro planeta y Mi pregunta es pensáis
que ahí se acaba todo pues no podéis
estar más equivocados para colmo en
diciembre de 2022 la justicia dictó
sentencia sobre una de las tantas causas
de corrupción que tiene abiertas
Cristina Fernández de kirchner la
condenaron de forma firme condenar a
Cristina Elizabeth Fernández de kirchner
a la pena de seis años de prisión
inhabilitación especial perpetua para
ejercer cargos públicos y claro con
semejante bagaje no nos puede sorprender
que el peronismo se haya hundido el
desastre ha sido colosal e incluso para
los cánones de la política Argentina de
hecho teniendo en cuenta todos los
acontecimientos que queréis que os diga
que el peronismo todavía siga cosechando
casi el 30% de los votos resulta
sorprendente Casi casi incomprensible
pero aún así su tercer puesto en las
paso es el fiel reflejo de todo lo que
ha pasado claro que el hundimiento del
peronismo no solo se explica por sus
propios errores en este caso la
oposición también ha tenido mucho que
ver atentos
[Música]
una oposición mucho más combativa
amigos especial desastre electoral de
2019 cuando los peronistas se hicieron
de nuevo con el timón del país cambiemos
la plataforma que había ocupado a
Mauricio macri no se disolvió ni se
fragmentó cambió su nombre por juntos
por el cambio y pese a muchas batallas
internas continuó unida eso fue algo que
les permitió hacer frente al gobierno
con mucha más fuerza lo que fue clave
para su Victoria en las últimas
legislativas del 2021 por primera vez en
mucho tiempo la alternativa al peronismo
no estaba dividida a las primarias de
2023 llegaron además con dos propuestas
muy diferentes por un lado tenemos a
Horacio Rodríguez larreta que venía de
sumar ocho años al frente de la jefatura
de gobierno de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
la recta tiene un perfil moderado y se
ha mostrado más abierto a dialogar con
el peronismo para buscar espacios
comunes lo que le valió el Mote de
Paloma por otro lado estaba Patricia
bullrich ex ministra de seguridad de
Mauricio macri y una candidata con
muchos menos problemas a la hora de
pegarse con los sindicatos y el
kirchnerismo bullrich era el halcón y
ahora las paso han decidido que sea la
candidata de Juntos por el cambio
[Música]
Claro que al final no fue ni ella ni
tampoco su formación política los
grandes protagonistas de las paso el
protagonista y el gran triunfador ha
sido sin duda Javier milei un economista
outsider que ha convertido su Campaña en
una enorme arenga No ya contra el
gobierno sino contra todo el modelo
político de la Argentina
yo no me metí acá para estar guiando
corderos Yo me metí acá para despertar
leones Quiero escucharlos
[Aplausos]
cuando la Argentina entró al siglo 20
era el país más rico del mundo
Argentina tenía una de las monedas más
sólidas del mundo
millones de inmigrantes agolpaban en
nuestras costas para poder tener la
chance de un futuro mejor
éramos la envidia del mundo sin embargo
en un momento la clase política decidió
que la riqueza de los argentinos no
podía estar en manos de los argentinos
sino que tenía que estar en las manos de
ellos mi ley promete acabar de raíz con
todos los males económicos de la
Argentina hablar de dolarizar la
economía suprimir gran parte del Estado
bajar los impuestos y En definitiva
romper con el que ha sido el modelo
económico político de la Argentina
Durante los últimos 70 80 o incluso 90
años te ha pedido erguita para el
déficit fiscal Y si le jode de repente
tener que ir a buscar guita para
dolarizar la economía y terminar con la
inflación te das cuenta que es un modelo
de saqueo te das cuenta que son un
conjunto de delincuentes hijos de con un
programa agresivo y tremendamente
ambicioso prácticamente revolucionario
logró un enorme triunfo
[Música]
apenas nadie lo vio venir pero Miley se
hizo con más del 30% de los votos ganó
en 16 provincias y se impuso tanto en
algunos de los barrios más populares
como en los pueblos más prósperos de la
Argentina sin embargo un momento porque
mi ley todavía no es presidente Sí ahora
ya podemos hablar de él como una
candidatura favorita pero todavía queda
carrera por delante por un lado milake
tendrá que expandir su techo electoral
para ser presidente necesita conseguir
más votos las paso han dejado el mapa
político muy abierto solo 2,8 puntos
separan a las tres grandes formaciones
políticas y aquí se dan dos
circunstancias contrapuestas por un lado
el perfil histriónico de Miley puede no
encajar mucho con el electorado que
busca un cambio pero no una Revolución
que sorprendentemente sigue siendo muy
grande de hecho la abstención fue muy
alta casi un tercio del lectorado se
quedó en casa y el juego en de octubre
puede ser algo diferente recordad que en
Argentina el voto es obligatorio y que
la participación suele superar el 80%,
más de 11 puntos más de la participación
que hemos visto en esta especie de
preelecciones Entre 10 y 13 puntos más
que en un escenario tan igualado a
tercios pueden cambiarlo todo pero por
otra parte qué demonios milei ha ganado
las paso y en política la victoria Llama
a Victoria a partir de hoy el voto a
este candidato ya es un voto
perfectamente útil ni con los argentinos
a sumarse la revolución liberal que va a
ser que el 35 años Argentina vuelva a
ser
una posterior Muchas gracias y
[Aplausos]
Jo pero incluso de llegar a la
presidencia se enfrentaría a otro
importante problema
[Música]
Y es que veréis en Argentina la cámara
de diputados renueva cada dos años la
mitad de sus miembros y el senado solo
se renueva por tercios es decir un
gobierno que llegue desde cero al poder
sin bloques previos en el parlamento lo
tendría muy difícil para hacer cambios
importantes sea como sea lo que está
claro es que argentina se enfrenta Sí o
sí a un cambio sísmico los argentinos
han dicho basta por primera vez el
peronismo se ha hundido y por primera
vez la alternativa es claramente
mayoritaria de una forma u otra todo
apunta a que Argentina va a cambiar pero
de todo eso hablaremos en un próximo
vídeo ahora la pregunta es será este el
final del peronismo quién se hará
finalmente con la presidencia creéis que
Argentina logrará salir adelante podrán
llegar las banderas libertarias a la
casa rosada Y si nos estás viendo desde
el país gaucho A qué candidato apoyas
déjanos respuestas en los comentarios y
hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo te
ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle al botón de like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo has
hecho muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]